Knitting away in tuck.
It's getting late and oops, I dropped a
bunch of stitches when trying to shape an
arm hole.
Now for me, picking up in tuck is
nearly impossible in desperation.
Determined not to have to start all over.
I tried four different techniques to pick
up the last row of plain knitting before I
started tuck.
First I picked up a small
circular hand knitting needle.
Now, this is normally my go-to method,
but I was only able to find a bamboo
needle and it was really clumsy to pick up
the stitches in this ribbon yard.
Next, I used a double eye needle to
run a strand through the stitches.
But that felt like driving a truck.
It was just too thick and bulky.
So I use the same idea of running a strand
of yarn through the stitches, and I found
a tapestry needle to work much better.
Finally, I had the brilliant idea.
That using a fine wire from the
ribber cast on comb would work.
Yep.
It was fine enough to pick up the
stitches, but you may have already guessed
the flaw in this idea.
Okay.
I was sure that all the stitches were
picked up in one way or another, and I
carefully ripped out all the tuck
now to rehang all those stitches.
Rehanging the stitches from the hand
knitting needle would have been a whole
lot easier if I had taken time to
find a smaller metal circular needle.
rehanging the stitches from the
pink strand of yarn wasn't too bad.
But there was a closed end on the cast on
comb wire that I used, I had to transfer
all of those stitches from the wire to
the hand knitting needle, then rehang the
stitches on the needle bed.
Oh my gosh.
A blocking wire would have
been a much better choice.
Finally, all the stitches are back on the
bed and I'm ready to knit in tuck again,
not until after a good night's sleep.
Lessons learned use lifelines.
If I had left the waste yarn on after I
rehung the gathered skirt, or if I had
added a lifeline after creating that
pretty join and all this is is an e-wrap
join, I wouldn't be using
swear words right now.
Lesson number two quit
before you get stupid tired.
Nuff said.
I hope you don't have to struggle like I
did, but if you do, maybe my experience
will help you.
Happy knitting.